en plena crisis del combustible el
accidente mortal de esta madrugada en la
ciudad fronteriza da la cara por la
explosión de un camión cisterna con
gasolina es otro ejemplo más de cómo el
líbano está atrapado entre la corrupción
y la negligencia aunque todavía se
desconocen las causas del incidente
medios locales dijeron que el ejército
había detenido al camión en cuestión que
transportaba gasolina subsidiada para
ser vendida en el mercado negro en síria
ahora que en el líbano hay mucha escasez
de combustible los hospitales han
advertido que en los próximos días
podrían dejar de funcionar si no se
resuelve el problema de los subsidios
para la importación de combustible la
decisión del banco central de quitar las
subvenciones a la gasolina ocurre en un
momento en el que los libaneses
prácticamente dependen de los
generadores de diésel para tener
electricidad porque hay 20 horas de
apagones diarios
esto también ocurre en medio de la peor
crisis económica y si se mantienen o se
levantan los subsidios significaría que
dos galones de gasolina equivaldría al
sueldo medio de un libanés